à l'abri des caméras françois legault
prépare sa 105e conférence de presse sur
la pandémie
une grande nouvelle aujourd'hui parce
que vacciner c'est gagné il prend son
premier bain de foule en un an
parmi les travailleurs de la santé qui
se font vacciner lors mais ils m'ont dit
que c'est déjà fini
merci à tous les deux on va travail
allez vous fabriquez vous moi j'aime
faire vacciner car mon argent va muer
jeu centre au hasard je n'ai pas passé
devant personne les québécois souhaitent
qu'on respecte les règles notamment ses
règles qu'il a imposé au fil des mois
sont loin d'avoir fait l'unanimité lundi
proche des eaux contestées
est ce que vous avez perdu des animaux
noms des vrais amis on perd jamais ça à
cause d'une chicane comme ça c'est plus
des connaissances
elle m'a donné c'est pas un équilibre
qui est fascinant dont l'appétit est ce
qu'un doctorat ou encore l'homme de la
situation
absolument je pense que c'est quelqu'un
d'abord qu'ils aient connaissance
deuxièmement qu'une bonne équipe en
dessous de lui ça vous dérange que son
étoile est parlé par rapport au
printemps mais la même chose pour moi
lorsque actuellement il ya des québécois
qui trouvent que je trop dur que je vais
trop loin
puis des québécois qui trouvent que je
vais passer loin que je trouvais l'os
sans même chose avec le docteur arruda
à kaunas et horatio échanges d'avant
françois malgré les critiques il est
faux pas ce n'a jamais été mon intention
de blesser qui que ce soit
il ne compte pas se départir de son
directeur de santé publique c'est la
prérogative du premier ministre de faire
des choix comme il l'a fait avec sa
ministre daniel mais cannes daniel c'est
quelqu'un qui collaborent écoute
concilie elle l'a très bien fait mais
c'était très épuisante
vla sentiers puiser ce que je chante
elle sait que tout le monde est épuisé
c'était dur après de douloureuses
réformes
il pense que le réseau de la santé avait
besoin de la douceur de daniel mais
cannes mais que cette qualité était
devenu son défaut ce souk à la peau le
même caractère que christian dubé c'est
un autre style
moi je vous dirais que daniel mais kahn
était la meilleure personne
après kate arborait pour apaiser les
réseaux puis re motiver les réseaux je
pense que christian une approche un peu
plus car ce qui est nécessaire
actuellement parce que il ya un travail
à faire sur l'imputabilité
il s'est rendu compte lui aussi qu'il
fallait parfois sortir le bâton sans
toutefois aller jusqu'à saluer la
méthode barrette
une nouvelle ministre est une femme
dominique savoie
il ajoute que l'autre sous ministre au
coeur de la gestion de crise lucio
patagonie est également réputé pour sa
main de fer entre autres en ce qui
concerne les listes d'attentes des
chirurgies ce qu'elle me dit puis moins
je la crois c'est que y'a aucune
chirurgies urgentes où il ya une
question de vie ou de mort qui était
reporté élégance âge progresse pas
brader cancer qui progresse mais les
balises sont respectées quand quelqu'un
besoin d'être opéré pour le camp ça y
est opérée pour le cancer
le premier ministre assure que le
délestage de chirurgie n'a fait aucun
mort jusqu'à maintenant il a même
vérifié du pu allumer des lampions lance
vraiment à l'étape d'agir durant cette
crise le seul qui a manqué de point grey
betty elle c'est son homologue justin
trudeau le visage de françois legault se
crispe dès qu'on aborde le sujet il ya
des décisions qui ont été prises par
justin trudeau avec lesquels jeta pas
d'accord de toute évidence leurs
relations se sont dégradées durant la
pandémie
allez vous travailler monsieur legault
d'affaires bac mais ce trou d'eau lors
de la prochaine élection écouter on en
voit d'abord comme en chute ou de vol
évolué mais il refuse d'admettre que la
politique a pris le dessus pour lui
certaines décisions tardives de justin
trudeau ont nui aux efforts pour freiner
la pandémie
parce qu'il responsable d'une partie des
problèmes c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de me dire ben écoutez il ya le
virus qui rentrait par des frontières
donc est-ce qu'on aurait dû être plus
rapide a fermé les frontières
moi je pense que oui mais ça relève du
fédéral
et quant à sa propre part de
responsabilité
sorti ce qu'il y aura le déclenchement
d'une enquête publique indépendante
c'est non non et encore non à une
enquête publique
la commissaire à la santé examine déjà
la performance du réseau
la majorité des chefs d'état auquel il
se compare on choisit un mécanisme
semblable est ce que les autres
provinces sont bornés à ce que d autres
pays sont bornés je pense que
actuellement ce qui était surtout
important c'est d'avoir un rapport
rapide donc on parle de septembre cette
année 2021
déjà on a fait beaucoup de changements
pas
françois legault sait très bien que ce
n'est pas encore fini les impacts de la
pandémie se feront sentir longtemps même
dans sa propre famille l'une de mes ça
qui est devenue grand-mère donc maman
est devenu arrière grand mère peut pas
voir son petit que maintenant 1-1 presse
c'est dur le chemin vers le retour à la
normale sera encore long et probablement
cahoteux
[Musique]